[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour l'instant benhaim été le cas ce qu
on va un petit peu on va faire un petit
blind
on va essayer de trouver des lits
seychelles temps les lettons de riga sur
celui qui trouve il gagne et égale le
droit
2 quand il lève la main il aura la
priorité ce soir c'est des comédies
musicales les épinards sa nana na na
même
ana
je les anniversaires nana na na na n'est
à ce problème
non
auxerre l'opéra rock exact
c'est
[Musique]
le sien
ok les gars sur l'école et quand ils ont
écrit le truc peur ils sont prêts à la
rousse et résines et un dos je maudis la
fatale et résidents non médicaux à ma
bonne réponse
[Applaudissements]
rosa le schéma
voilà une chanson écrite par bison futé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi o'keefe et ont kiffé garçon qui
sait est l'outil l'arrivée nous a
flingué colère troisième et dernier
titre à raser le quatrième siècle
dernier parce que vous nous faites chier
aller au débat na na na nana na na c'est
quoi
[Musique]
on sait bien compris bien mal un beau
duo jeu la dorsale ah non excusez moi
pourquoi est ce que je vois mon idée
quoiqu'en benhaim est choqué c'est la
nuit qu'on macias et mon essentiel
[Applaudissements]
tu me le borgne
je
c'est
tu aimerais
personne
[Musique]
ça près
bravo est le grand gagnant edwards
yamaha 4 à 10
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]